[Music]
a new month is upon us which means new
releases is gonna take a top down look
at the video games coming in september
we've got heroes and villains
basketballs and hoops and plenty of
other fun pairings
let's check out some of the hottest
games coming soon
there may not be many marvel movies
happening right now but you can still
get your superhero fix with marvel's
avengers
the action game lets you take control of
a bunch of different heroes
each with their own special abilities
and comic based costumes
it's a team game so of course you can
battle through its many missions with
friends in co-op
you can suit up on ps4 xbox one pc and
stadia on friday september 4th
much like the movies sports are also
operating differently right now
but nba 2k 21 is still ready to walk
onto the court
as you'd expect this year's game has a
number of improvements
including better pro stick shooting and
dribbling plus a ton of new jump shots
and size ups
my team has also been revamped nba 2k 21
makes the jump onto ps4
xbox one pc stadia and switch on the 4th
sticking with sports the birdman is also
back this month with tony hawk's pro
skater 1 and 2.
yes that does mean you're getting the
first two games with this remaster
but it also includes tons of tricks and
options that didn't come to the series
till later
you can skate with others in both online
and split screen co-op and create your
own custom skaters in parks
i'll definitely be making my dark souls
themed park
anyway tony hawk 1 2 comes to ps4 xbox
one and pc
on the 4th that's not the only
re-release we're getting this month
either
thanks to crisis remastered the game
that was once used as a pc benchmark has
been pushed even further
with new 8k textures improved lighting
and the addition of ray tracing
gameplay wise expect a whole bunch of
action as you shoot your way across an
island of enemy soldiers and alien
invaders
using your super suits range of special
abilities crisis remastered is already
out on twitch but you can grab it on ps4
xbox one and pc on friday the 18th
september actually wraps up with one
more big remake
mafia definitive edition the original
2002 game has been completely rebuilt
from the ground up
with new story content and improved
gameplay you can watch crimes get
committed in 4k
if you've got the hardware for it too
you can return to the era of gangsters
and prohibition on ps4
xbox one and pc on friday the 25th
and those are some of the hottest games
launching all month long
as always remember that release dates
are based on retailer listings and are
subject to change
thanks for watching everyone and i'll be
back with a closer look at more
september games next sunday
you